5 start-up cinq propositions de mobilité
innovante c'est le challenge organisé
par l'association delta sky le principe
trouver des solutions pour la mobilité
des salariés de saint quentin en
yvelines
l'idée du chalenge c'était de de
susciter la créativité des start-up leur
agilité pour trouver des solutions
innovantes qui apportent des choses très
concrètes qui peuvent être mises en
oeuvre rapidement simplement
efficacement et dans un délai court qui
a des mobilités complémentaires et c'est
ça qui est un des c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est d'avoir un large panel
qui permettent justement de s'adapter
tous les profils et à tous les âges un
service de location de trottinettes
électriques en station une solution
développée par we trust
c'est le premier prix de ce challenge
avec un projet en cours d'élaboration
cinq à sept kilomètres autour de la gare
de saint quentin en yvelines
la zone était tendue elle va partir du
pôle mobilité du transport sur un à
trois kilomètres déjà pour démarrer sur
montigny et ensuite on va élargir sur la
clé sous bois et on travaille sur un
projet aussi son voisin bretonneux autre
start-up lauréate de ce concours ce
moving avec son concept de véhicule de
transport collectif et écologique en
forme de lieu de travail
c'est le mobile office l'idée c'est de
reproduire tout le le confort et les
services qu'on a dans un bureau fixe et
de le rendre mobiles et de faire en
sorte de transformer le temps de trajet
en temps de travail opérationnel avec le
confort et l'efficacité d'un bureau fixe
enfin supra wise a aussi obtenu un prix
cette start up est en train de
développer ce système de mobilité
innovants sur le territoire
[Musique]